remontons le temps et revenons au
moyen-âge les morts pas un ont pu
retourner au xvème siècle avec la
reconstitution d'un village médiéval est
mort parce qu'elles connaissent bien
leur histoire est d'ailleurs me semble
très passionné en fait hein c'est vrai
que deux d'année en année on s'aperçoit
qu'en fait l'histoire est important pour
pour les bords pas et on frise
historique sur le moyen-âge création de
photophores pour enfants ou encore
reconstitution d'une cathédrale en 3d
des animations proposées par
l'association mort pas d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui
suite à l'émotion suscitée par
l'incendié de notre dame de paris on a
créé cette maquette qui permet
d'apprendre le nom des pièces déjà les
contreforts le chevet le transept
on recherche des architectes et quand
les enfants arrivent en leur dis bravo
c'est l architecte nous attendions
s'était bien ou un atelier ludique qui a
plu aux nombreux enfants présents
retrouver les pièces c'est un peu
compliqué parce que elle se ressembler
un peu donc savoir de quelques tests
mettaient un peu difficile mais après
c'est ça a été un peu plus loin des
armures détente de l'époque médiéval
installé par les regrattiers d'histoire
votre propos c'est de reconstituer la
vie que pouvait rencontrer quelqu'un qui
serait rentré dans une bourgade de nos
régions là en ile de france
le campement médiéval immerge le public
dans le quotidien de l'époque
les visiteurs ont pu découvrir les
métiers de la laine et un tisserand mais
aussi les loisirs de l'époque échasses
chant et art
je vais essayer aussi là puisque c'est
un instrument qui est peu fréquent sur
les fêtes médiévales mais qui est assez
peu connue finalement en dehors des
grands arbres de concert ce campement
médiéval de maurepas a permis à petits
et grands de replonger dans l'histoire
et le patrimoine de cette ville qui
possède son donjon de cette époque
[Musique]